>> Tucker: TWO WEEKS AGO ONE
PERSON ACCUSED BRETT KAVANAUGH
OF ACCUSING A SEX CRIME IN
1982.
FOUR OTHER PEOPLE PRESENT DENY
IT HAPPENED.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS WE HAVE ON
THE TABLE.
FOR THIS, THE LEFT HAS CALLED
HIM A SEX CRIMINAL AND AN
ATTEMPTED RAPIST AND TRIED TO
DESTROY HIS LIFE.
HE FOUGHT BACK YESTERDAY.
NOW HIS PERSECUTORS HAVE A NEW
ARGUMENT.
WATCH.
>> WE KNOW ONE THING, HE DOES
NOT HAVE THE TEMPERAMENT TO BE
A JUDGE.
>> HE BASICALLY HAD A TANTRUM
AND SHOWED THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE THE TEMPERAMENT TO BE A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
>> FELT LIKE OH, THAT IS WHAT
HE IS LIKE WHEN HE IS ANGRY
AND BELLIGERENT WHEN HE IS
DRUNK.
>> HIS TEMPERAMENT IS NOT
SUITED.
>> MY OPPOSITION SOLIDIFIED
BECAUSE OF TEMPERAMENT AND
FITNESS, WHICH I BELIEVE HE
LACKS.
>> Tucker: SENATOR
BLUMENTHAL DELIVERING HIS
VERDICT HERE.
CHRIS HAHN AN ATTORNEY AND
RADIO HOST AND FORMER AIDE TO
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE MOST OR WELLIAN
ARGUMENT I HAVE SEEN.
YOU ATTACK A GUY, AN ATTEMPTED
RAPIST AND A DRUNK, SOMEONE
UNFIT.
NOT JUST TO BE A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE BUT TO LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHEN HE GETS MAD ABOUT IT AND
HE DEFENDS HIMSELF, YOU SAY
LOOK AT HIM.
HE IS AN ABUSER BECAUSE HE GOT
MAD.
WHAT?
THAT IS TOO UNFAIR, ACTUALLY.
>> WELL, WHEN YOU ARE WEAK ON
THE LAW, -- WEAK ON THE FACTS,
POUND THE LAW.
IF YOU ARE WALK ON THE LAW,
POUND THE FACTS.
IF YOU ARE WEAK ON BOTH, YOU
POUND THE TABLE.
IT WAS A DISAPPOINTING DISPLAY
BY JUDGE KAVANAUGH, JUDGE
WOULD ACCEPT.
I WORKED IN THE FEDERAL COURTS
AND I WORKED IN THE STATE
COURTS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING YOU
ACCEPT FROM A LEVEL-HEADED
JURIST.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
BUT THE LEVEL-HEADED JURIST
WAS JUST ACCUSED OF A SEX
CRIME.
HE SAYS HE DIDN'T COMMIT.
HIS REPUTATION HAS BEEN
DESTROYED.
HE WILL NEVER WORK AGAIN
UNLESS HE GETS THIS JOB.
YOU KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE.
IF I SAID HEY, CHRIS --
>> NO, THIS IS A LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT.
>> Tucker: IF SOMEONE SAID
ANONYMOUSLY THAT YOU ARE A
RAPIST.
I WILL TELL YOUR KIDS ABOUT IT
AND THEY WON'T SPEAK TO YOU
AND YOUR NEIGHBORS WON'T SPEAK
TO IT.
THIS HAPPENED TO ME.
I WAS UPSET.
IS IT OKAY BECAUSE IT'S
LEGITIMATE TO BE UPSET.
>> I WOULD NOT BE BEHAVING
LIKE A SUPREME COURT JUDICIAL
NOMINEE.
HE IS A SUPREME COURT JUDICIAL
WHO SHOULD ALWAYS PRESENT
HIMSELF AS --
>> Tucker: HOW SHOULD
SENATORS BEHAVE?
ESPECIALLY THE MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE?
SHOULD THEY BE HONEST AND
FAIR?
TRYING TO DESTROY HIM?
>> DO WHATEVER THE VOTERS
ACCEPT.
SENATORS STAND BEFORE THE
VOTERS AND ARE APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS.
THIS MAN STANDS BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> Tucker: HOWEVER VOTERS
WILL ACCEPT?
>> HE IS GOING FOR A LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT, SIR.
A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT.
TUCKER, C'MON.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A HIGHER
STANDARD.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THE MOST
REVEALING ANSWER I GOT.
IT'S FRIDAY.
AT THE END OF THE SHOW --
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> Tucker: TOOK THIS LONG TO
GET A CLEAR ANSWER.
BEHAVE HOWEVER THE VOTERS
WANT.
>> YOU ALWAYS WANT A CLEAR
ANSWER.
>> Tucker: I'LL THINK ABOUT
IT ALL WEEKEND.
ALMOST OUT OF TIME.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, DONALD TRUMP SAID
SPECIFICALLY THERE SHOULD BE
NO DOUBT.
HOW COULD WE HAVE NO DOUBT
AFTER YESTERDAY?
SORRY, THERE IS PLENTY OF
DOUBT OF KAVANAUGH'S STORY.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT A
PARTISAN REPUBLICANS.
I DON'T LIKE THE REPUBLICANS
MUCH.
I WATCHED THEM YESTERDAY AND I
FELT FOR HIM.
I TURN ON THE OTHER CHANNELS
AND THAT ARE LIKE "WHITE
PRIVILEGE!"
WE DON'T SEE THE WORLD THE
SAME WAY AT ALL.
>> THE QUESTION, THE
QUESTION -- DID YOU BELIEVE
HER?
>> Tucker: I BELIEVED HER.
I THINK SHE THINKS SHE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE SHE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH BUT I
BELIEVE SHE BELIEVES IT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE.
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION.
I FEEL SORRY FOR HER.
OUT OF TIME.
CHRIS, THANK YOU.
>> MOST PEOPLE RELIVING A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE DON'T
HAVE EVIDENCE OF IT 30 YEARS
LATER.